Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Seize milliards,
c’est le nombre de pots de yaourt
qui sont consommés chaque année en France.
À l’échelle mondiale,
ça représente 15 millions de tonnes de
plastique qui sont produites chaque année
seulement pour cet emballage.
Malheureusement, on recycle seulement 5%
de la totalité des emballages plastiques.
Le reste est incinéré car ils sont trop
fins, trop cassants, trop complexes.
Bien sûr, le plastique, on voudrait
tous pouvoir s’en passer.
Mais on sait aussi qu’il présente
des caractéristiques particulières
qui le rendent difficilement remplaçable.
Aujourd’hui, je viens
vous présenter notre solution
qui permet de combiner
les avantages du plastique
tout en réduisant son impact
négatif sur l’environnement.
Parfois, la nature nous
chuchote des réponses.
Notre innovation est basée
sur l’utilisation d’enzymes.
Vous connaissez certainement
celles qui, par exemple,
dans nos organismes,
nous aident à digérer nos aliments.
Nous nous sommes demandé
si ces enzymes pouvaient aussi
nous aider à dégrader les plastiques.
Notre idée a donc été d'introduire ces
enzymes directement dans les plastiques
pour les rendre 100% compostables
sous la forme d'un additif.
Elles sont introduites directement au
moment de la fabrication des emballages
pour le rendre donc compostable
dans votre composteur de jardin.
Aujourd’hui, cet additif
fonctionne sur le PLA -
l’acide poly-lactique pour les intimes -
qui est un polymère d’origine végétale,
c’est-à-dire qu’il peut être produit
à partir d’amidon de maïs
ou de canne à sucre.
Double avantage donc.
D’une part, un polymère, un plastique,
biosourcé et non pétrosourcé,
c’est-à-dire qui permet la réduction
de 75% de l’empreinte carbone,
et également complètement biodégradable
dans votre compost de jardin.
Mais rassurez-vous, ce pot de yaourt ne
va pas se désintégrer dans votre frigo
puisque l'enzyme a besoin de conditions
particulières pour s'activer.
C’est seulement dans votre compost
de jardin que l’enzyme va s’activer
et démarrer la biodégradation du pot.
Ce pot de yaourt se dégradera complètement
en moins de six mois
dans votre compost de jardin.
Pour information, c’est plus rapide
que la dégradation d’une feuille de chêne
ramassée dans le jardin.
Vous le savez peut-être,
le compostage sera demain
une réalité pour tous les Européens.
D'ici 2023, chacun d'entre vous
devra trier ses biodéchets.
Et grâce à notre solution,
ces pots de yaourt pourraient
également y être intégrés.
Notre ambition pour 2030,
c’est de réduire d’un tiers l’incinération
des pots de yaourt en France,
qui ne peuvent pas être recyclés.
Pour atteindre cet objectif,
on est persuadé
qu’il faut agir à plusieurs niveaux.
Réduire, évidemment,
réutiliser quand c’est possible
ou remplacer quand c'est pertinent.
Le recyclage reste
la meilleure des options.
Et dans notre cas, votre pot de yaourt
passera ainsi de déchets en ressources
dans votre compost.
La bonne nouvelle, c’est que
le PLA peut aussi être utilisé
pour la fabrication
d’autres types d’emballages,
ce qui ouvre un vaste
champ d’application possible.
Je vous le dis, ce que je tiens
dans mes mains depuis trois minutes,
c’est un petit pot pour l’homme
et un grand pas
pour la fin de vie des plastiques.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)